I'm here again to give you some helpful
advice about what you should read and
what you shouldn't read and specifically
who you shouldn't bother with reading
everybody Raves about this guy Philip K
dick look they even put uh a whole bunch
of his novels into this library of
America
editions with nice paper and the special
ribbon bookmarks but it's all just silly
sci-fi stuff why would you want to waste
your time on that he's written all sorts
of short stories as well and you could
waste hours and hours and hours reading
this stuff
instead maybe you should just watch
television shows and movies if you've
got a hankering for the man in the High
Castle you don't need to read a novel
they've already got a whole show about
that if you want to read the Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep why bother with
that when you can just watch the Blade
Runner and we could go through story and
story and novel and novel there have
been so many adaptations of this guy's
writings that you basically don't need
to read or even listen to them
somebody's already taken all the best
parts and digested them and thrown them
onto the Silver Screen or the screen of
your phone or that of your laptop or you
can watch these things to your heart's
content and I'd really suggest that you
don't bother with this headcracker the
Exige basis of Philip K dick it's just a
bunch of crazy ramblings that don't
really give us anything useful I mean
dick does talk an awful lot about his
own Works in here but we've already
established that his Works aren't really
that coherent I mean listen to this this
is an entry where he says that uh
there's all of these stories that should
be read and real as one narrative who
uses pretentious language like that
Stigmata maze ubic tears and scanner
he's even on a first name basis with his
own writings this is clearly the work of
a deranged mind so I wouldn't spend too
much time on this person and his thought
and his works and trying to figure out
if there there's some sort of meaning or
message behind it or implications like I
said anything that's truly worthwhile in
his Works hasn't it already been mined
by Hollywood directors by Netflix
producers and show Runners there's no
sense in screwing around with Dick and
even becoming a [__] that's the name
of his fans that will close on that I
mean what sort of goofball would allow
his followers to be named [__] and
to be made the subject of derision and
satire in such a way so if you find this
advice helpful maybe I can give you some
other good literary advice sometime down
the road about what to read and
definitely what not to read